Celebrate the summer with some patriotic rubber
ducks that you can float in your 4th of July
inflatable cooler because it's episode 42
of LÜT.
Watch sounds on your iPhone with this equalizer
phone case and transform your homework into
something that's more than meets the eye with
one of these Transformer pens.
For a different kind of transformation turn
your bottles into lamps with rechargeable
lights shaped like corks.
Then use this smart cup to figure out where
all of those empty bottles came from. The
Vessyl recognizes and tracks everything that
you drink including caffeine levels, nutritional
values, and can even distinguish between brands.
Or just play with your drinks by shooting
some hoops with this one instead. Then pack
your cookies that taste like cupcakes inside
a peanut butter and jelly sandwich... storage
pocket.
For a no mess friend play with blob and flow
light up pets that plug in via USB and respond
with different light sequences depending on
the touch or just use emergency googly eyes
to bring anything inanimate to life.
For something life-less decorate with this
unicorn head plaque and display it next to
your preserved sheep's heart..... uhhhh
After completing the required operating course
you can purchase your own flyboard that can
rocket you 45 feet out of the water and finally
help you swim like a dolphin.
For something big but not quite as expensive
you can sail the skies in this giant 3D pirate
ship kite or win the World Cup of giants with
this huge soccer ball.
Kick back and let a drone catch the action
with Airdog, an auto-follow air drone that
works with a GoPro camera. Just attach a small
waterproof programmable tracker called the
air leash and the quadcopter will follow your
coordinates wherever you go.
Check in on your Fridgezoo fridge pets and
sit down for a snack of canned dragon and
candy sushi while you read your paper later.
A service from the Newspaper club that prints
your desired articles from the internet into
a physical newspaper and sends it to you via
snail mail. It's currently only available
in the UK but they plan to expand to other
areas soon.
Conquer new territory with this bow and arrow
that shoots marshmallows and a 14 in 1 survival
watch that includes a compass, bottle opener,
fire starter, whistle, and signaling mirror.
Make sure everyone feels your presence with
Mybell, the first customizable digital horn
and light for bikes. Each one can hold two
digital sound files chosen by the user and
pre-selected LED lighting patterns.
Then make a rainbow with some sunlight and
crystals using this standing rainbow maker
and create 3D drawings with Creopop. Unlike
other 3D pens, this is the world's first to
use cool ink or photopolymers and doesn't
contain any heated parts or melting plastic.
The inks come in a variety of colors, elasticity,
and some are even magnetic.
Now for those of age - go aerate some wine
with a bendy straw while you sort out your
emotions by stuffing them into a Kimochi Emotion
doll and as always thanks for watching.